Now I know its really tempting to think that the answer is seven but this would
be a mistake. We know that the square root of five is really just a number. So
we have seven times one number minus one times another number. So if we have
seven of one number and we subtract one of that number. Then we'll six of that
number left. This is why this answer is really six times the square root of
five. If we think about factoring the square root of 5 from both of these
terms, we would be left with the quantity of 7 minus 1 times the square root of
5, and when we subtract, we'll get 6 times root 5. Another way to think about
this reasoning is with an object. If you thought the answer was seven, then
consider this, if we had seven cakes and subtracted a cake we wouldn't be left
with seven cakes we'd really be left with six cakes. This is sort of an analogy
for what's going on here we have seven cakes at root 5's minus one cake or 1
root 5. This leaves us left with 6 root 5.